Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Es ist Merz. Wir stehen vor dem Salon, um heute den Untergang zu begleiten, so würde ich sagen.
Welchen Untergang denn genau?
Trumps.
Ist dieses Buch das Ergebnis des Untergangs oder ist das Buch das Plädoyer für den Untergang?
Ist das Buch eine Gebrauchsanweisung für den Untergang?
Oder würdest du sagen, dieses Buch ist geschrieben gegen Donald Trump?
Nein. Alex Karp hat ein Buch geschrieben mit einer Idee, die er gerne verwirklicht
sehen möchte, von Donald Trump.
Und wir sehen jetzt, dass nicht nur wir finden, dass Donald Trump dumm ist,
sondern dass Alex Karp wahrscheinlich auch gerade die Hände über die Köpfe zusammenschlägt.
Nicht nur seine, sondern auch Peter Thiels Kopf.
Wir lesen sehr viel Peter Thiel-Ideologie in diesem Buch.
Und man sieht die Idee und man sieht den Ansatz.
Aber wie es nun mal so ist, man schickt die Achtjährigen auf die Strecke,
sie sollen so schnell laufen, wie sie können.
Sie verlassen ihre Bahn, sie stolpern über ihre eigenen Füße und am Ende kommt niemand ins Ziel.
Und dieses Buch dokumentiert es, finde ich, wenn man es klug und inspirativ
liest, auf wirklich sehr eindrückliche Art und Weise.
Ja, ich habe es nochmal anders gelesen. Also du hast vollkommen recht.
Nämlich in der Hinsicht, dass ich dachte,
ja, die Milliardäre, man hört es immer wieder, wollen Opernhäuser bauen oder
Tunnel durch die Alpen bohren oder einfach nur irgendwelche Superjachten besitzen und ich denke immer…,
Das ist schlimm, aber es geht auch viel schlimmer, nämlich so wie Alex Karp sich das ausdenkt.
In gewisser Weise ist es das erschreckendste Buch, das wir im Salon je gelesen
haben. Also ich bin wirklich schockiert darüber, finde es aber absolut zeitgemäß.
Ich glaube, es knüpft einem so viel an, dass ich erstaunt war beim Lesen,
aber ich habe mich selten so gegruselt,
auch weil es in einer fast argumentativen Redlichkeit erst einmal so tut,
als sei das doch das, was der gesunde Menschenverstand so wollen mag.
Und das ist ein wirklich erschreckendes Buch.
Von daher bin ich ja froh, es gibt auch, wie ich hier sehe, auch noch andere
Bücher zu lesen, die optimistischer sind oder naja, der Titel, Die Kinderwüste.
Dein Buch ist jetzt erschienen.
Heute ist Erscheinungstermin. Du kriegst es natürlich vom Autor persönlich überreicht.
Dankeschön, danke.
Denn die Kiste von Hoffmann und Kamp ist auch bei mir jetzt endlich angekommen.
Das letzte Buch, das ich hatte, war ja ein Diebstahl von mir, von der Signieraktion.
Ich habe mir einfach einen, wo der Umschlag so ein bisschen kaputt war,
mitgenommen. Jetzt ist es da, es ist, du hast ja schon betont,
am Ende geht es auch um Weltpolitik.
Es geht die ganze Zeit um die Verklammerung kleiner und großer Politik.
Ich beginne mit Dunja Hayali und sage, man kann nicht im Heute-Schnall stehen
und sagen, der Staatshaushalt, jeder der einen Haushalt führt,
weiß ja, woran es jetzt mangelt. Nein, diese Verknüpfung gibt es nicht und die
Verknüpfungen sind anders.
Ich stelle da, wie die Politik immer auf die Familie zu sprechen kommt,
aber nie auf die Familie, sondern immer auf das ideale Bild der Pastorenfamilie,
weil man so auch den Staat organisiert.
Helft den Nachbarn, achte auf Oma und Opa und so weiter und so fort.
Also die Floskeln sind ja alle da, nur es passt immer nie.
Und am Ende das große Finale natürlich, was ist mit China und Russland?
Dort gibt es auch feministische Politik, feministische akademische Politik,
Beratung und so weiter, weil auch in China 600 Millionen Frauen leben,
die nicht einfach nicht mal in China tun, wie ihnen gesagt wird.
Und der amerikanische Versuch jetzt den Frauen zu sagen, wo es lang geht,
wird natürlich, also werden wir nachher diskutieren, platzt gerade in der Hinsicht,
es ist kein Buch über Gedöns.
Es gibt genug Bücher über die Gefühligkeit von Familie und wie erziehe ich meine
Kinder und wie bringe ich sie zum Schlafen und was ist, wenn sie picky eater
sind, sondern es gibt andere Dimensionen.
Und ich habe ja beim letzten Mal schon bemerkt, wie schnell sich Debatten drehen
im September 2022 kam die Altenrepublik damals war der Fachkräftemangel noch
ein, das ist ja so eine Industrieideologie und heute wissen wir,
nein, wir diskutieren anders darüber und wir haben es jetzt gerade diese Woche gesehen,
wie Friedrich Merz noch im Fernsehen sitzt und sagt,
Verschuldung niemals Frau Maischberger in dem Fall auch in diesem Studio sitzen
junge Leute den können wir jetzt nicht sagen, dass wir deren Geld schon mal
ausgeben müssen Und eine Woche später wird das Vorzeichen einmal komplett umgedreht.
Und zwar richtig kräftig.
Wie es sich nicht mal die SPD getraut hat, im Wahlkampf zu sagen.
Ja, es stand nicht so im Wahlprogramm. Also die SPD ging ja in dem Wahlprogramm
verglichen mit anderen relativ weit.
Aber das ist weit davon entfernt geblieben, was man jetzt gerade macht.
Von daher, der Ansatz meines Buches ist, wenn man es durchgelesen hat,
140 Seiten absolviert, schafft man auf einer Zugfahrt, dass man danach sagt, Familie...
So geht es nicht weiter. Wir brauchen jetzt ein neues Vorzeichen.
Es ist der große Systemstreit. Und alle mittendrin.
Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich freue mich sehr. Der Untertitel, wie die Politik
Familien im Stich lässt.
Und da steckt natürlich auch die Aufforderung drin, dass die Politik es nicht
mehr tun sollte. Aber erstmal sieht es düster aus.
Sehr düster. Wir haben ein Investitionsprogramm in Brücken, Pranzer,
immerhin ein bisschen Schule. Wir wissen nicht genau, wie viel dann da hängen bleibt.
Und gestern gab es ja eine Meldung, dass ein Bundesland jetzt gesagt hat,
als zentrale Anordnung, vier Unterrichtsstunden weniger pro Woche für alle Schüler
als Beitrag für die Haushaltslage.
Wahnsinn.
Man kann es sich nicht vorstellen.
Nein, es ist katastrophal, aber wir bleiben bei den katastrophalen Themen.
Du hast wahrscheinlich auch dir Trump und Zelensky angesehen.
Wie wirkte das Ganze auf dich?
Ich schaue mir jetzt alles gerne an, wo Trump auf dem letzten Loch pfeift.
Wir haben sowas wie im Oval Office noch.
Hattest du den Eindruck, ja.
Also ich habe derzeit konstant nur den Eindruck.
Ja, das finde ich interessant. Ich habe den Eindruck nämlich nicht.
Also ich habe ja jetzt mehrfach, okay, dann schildere ich erstmal meine Beobachtung.
Ich habe jetzt mehrfach betont, dass sich Donald Trump bisher noch nicht zum Kongress getraut hat,
sondern hat ihm einfach so ein Bill hingelegt, so ein Haushaltsgesetz und das
ist One Beautiful Bill, wie es halt so heißt, in dem er alles mit einmal regeln
will, weil er weiß, ich kann mich auf Streitereien dort nicht einlassen.
Ich kriege nicht mal meinen eigenen Minister durch. Ich brauche J.D.
Vance, der dort einen Tie-Break, obwohl ich eine Drei-Stimmen-Mehrheit habe,
bricht, damit die Senatoren sagen, ja gut, der AFK kann doch mal Gesundheitsminister werden.
So, Donald Trump ist jetzt zum Kongress gegangen.
Es ist sozusagen der größtmögliche Auftritt, den ein amerikanischer Präsident haben kann.
Den kann man aber nicht unendlich oft machen.
So wir hatten nicht nur die Oval Office Situation mit,
Zelensky, sondern wir hatten auch die mit Kirstama, wo Kirstama meinte ich habe hier einen Brief,
von His Majesty und so, er lädt sie ein das gab es noch nie,
es ist der zweite Staatsbesuch für einen amerikanischen Präsidenten üblicherweise
gibt es nur einen und so weiter,
also alles was wir an Semantik erleben ist das Maximum.
Es lässt sich nicht nochmal toppen.
Und wir sind erst im ersten Monat.
Ja.
Es muss aber immer weiter getoppt werden, das ist das Programm.
Also wo soll das hinführen?
Es ist alles ausgereizt. Und die Bedrohungslage ist soweit auch ausgereizt.
Mhm. So.
Und das sieht man insbesondere bei Zelensky.
Wenn wir jetzt auf dieses konkrete Treffen kommen, wie hat denn das auf dich
gewirkt? Also hast du nur diese 10 Minuten gesehen oder diese 50 Minuten?
Weil wenn man sich diese 50 Minuten ansieht, was ich auch erst dann viel später
getan habe, dann bekommt man ja doch einen anderen Eindruck.
Ich glaube, ich brauche jetzt hier keinen Disclaimer zu machen,
dass ich Trump blöd finde und ich das alles sehr verantwortungslos finde etc.
Nur gab mir etwas zu denken und zwar Jochen Bittner von der Zeit.
Also ein Transatlantiker, ein Konservativer, jemand, dessen Artikel ich jetzt
nicht besonders schätze, dessen Meinung aber dann ja doch mitunter bei aller
Kontraintuition für mich dann interessant ist.
War auf Twitter zu lesen.
Er schrieb dort oder auf X.
Natürlich haben sich Trump und Vance vollkommen würdelos und autoritär gegenüber
Zelensky und der Ukraine verhalten.
Aber was ist in den ganzen 50 Minuten der Pressekonferenz passiert?
Nicht nur in den letzten 10 Minuten. Und dann schreibt er, Selenskyj hatte offenbar
die Erwartung, dass die USA bei den Verhandlungen auf der Seite der Ukraine
stehen, um Putin zu stoppen.
Er ging davon aus, dass es keine Kompromisse bei Gebietsfragen geben könne und
er wollte starke militärische Sicherheitsgarantien.
Trump machte daraufhin noch einmal klar, was er seit langem sagt,
dass er auf keiner Seite stehe, sondern in der Mitte.
Und das bedeutet bei den eigenen nationalen Interessen und so weiter.
Diese Position war längst klar, schreibt Trump.
Zelensky hat aber nicht darauf entsprechend reagiert.
Für ihn stellte das, und das sagt Bittner hier auch verständlicherweise als Verrat da,
aber er sagt dann auch, der zweite Fehler von Zelensky war dann,
dass er die ganze Politikmethode von Trump in Zweifel gezogen hat,
indem er bestritt, dass man mit Putin Deals machen könne.
So, und ich habe mir dann daraufhin, also nur aufgrund dieses Tweets,
habe ich mir dann diese 50 Minuten angesehen und dachte, ja,
da hat der Bittner einen Punkt.
Ja klar.
Denn es war hochinteressant. Wir wissen ja, Trump ist unberechenbar,
aber wir wissen auch in gewisser Weise, wie er tickt und was geht und was nicht geht.
Also man kann zum Beispiel Donald Trump nicht unterbrechen. Das ist einfach verboten.
Man muss ihm einen Brief zeigen des Königs, der eine einmalige Einladung ausspricht und alles andere.
Ich sage nicht, dass ich das, also ist verständlich die Reaktion von,
also direkt zutiefst menschlich die Reaktion von Silensky und all das.
Nur, ich gehe nur strategisch, blicke ich darauf und dann denke ich,
nee, das ist keine gute Strategie.
Trump beginnt diese Konferenz damit, dass er sagt, wir machen einen Deal,
ich bin ein Dealmaker, wir brauchen jetzt ein Ende dieses Sterbens etc.
Und er hat mit Putin gesprochen und auch mit Präsident Zelensky schon und dass
sie sich da einig werden und sowas. Also er verbreitet gute Stimmung.
Daraufhin hat dann Zelensky das Wort und sagt, ja also Putin ist ein Terrorist,
Putin ist ein Killer. Kompromisse mit einem Killer, wie geht das?
Das kann ich natürlich so sehen und das setzt einen auch moralisch auf die richtige Seite.
Nur strategisch gegenüber Trump, der gerade sagt, ich habe jetzt mal mit allen
gesprochen und wir leiten da was ein, ist das natürlich maximal blöde.
Und das hat ja auch dann dazu geführt und das schaukelte sich immer weiter hoch.
Also ich würde jedem empfehlen, sich das mal ganz anzusehen.
Natürlich ist das eine Situation, die darauf ausgelegt ist, dass es zu so Eklats kommen kann.
Natürlich ist auch bemerkenswert, dass Trump das Ganze beendet mit,
I think we have seen enough, what do you think, fragt er die Journalisten,
great television und damit beendet er das Ganze.
Also der wirkliche Affront liegt ja darin, dass das in der Öffentlichkeit ausgetragen wird.
Denn dass Präsidenten so mit anderen Präsidenten sprechen, gerade US-amerikanische,
ist nicht ein Novum, was wir hier erlebt haben. Das Novum ist,
dass wir dabei sein konnten.
Bojan Panschewski, der ja diese großartigen Recherchen gemacht hat zu den Nord
Stream 2 Sprengungen, hat auch zum Beispiel darauf hingewiesen auf Twitter, dass...
Biden, auch 22, mit Zelensky heftig aneinander gerasselt ist,
nur hinter verschlossenen Türen. Das hat man dann mal so rausgefunden.
Obama mit den Europäern über dieselben Fragen auch.
Immer wieder geschieht sowas, nur nicht auf offener Bühne. Das ist eben das Neue.
Wir wissen, Trump versteht sich als Fernsehstar und weil du sagst,
naja Trump ist angeschlagen und so weiter.
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass Trump doch hier wirklich strategisch für seine Interessen
ziemlich weit vorangekommen ist.
Er hat dafür gesorgt, dass es diesen Eklat dann am Ende gibt.
Also er hat natürlich dann Zelensky nicht gebremst und dann haben sie sich gegenseitig
reingesteuert. Dann kam J.D.
Vance noch dazu und hat das dann noch alles beschleunigt.
Aber das hat ja dazu geführt, dass Selenskyj dann zu Keir Starmer gereist ist,
dort die anderen EU-Spitzen traf und von denen eigentlich aufgefordert wurde,
diesen Brief an Trump zu schreiben. Jetzt scheint Selenskyj wieder bald zu Trump zu reisen.
Die Europäer haben entsprechend reagiert, indem sie sagen, wie viele Trillionen
brauchen wir für die Aufrüstung, die EU, Deutschland, alle haben darauf jetzt
reagiert, auf das, was da vorgefallen ist.
Und zugleich bedeutet das ja nicht das Ende der transatlantischen Partnerschaft,
denn Merz ist ein Transatlantiker, die gesamte CDU besteht aus Transatlantikern
und man kann davon ausgehen, dass ja auch viele dieser Milliarden,
die jetzt freigemacht werden,
investiert werden in der Form, dass man amerikanische Waffen kauft,
was der amerikanischen Volkswirtschaft wieder dienlich sein wird.
Also ich sehe, dass Trump fürchterlich agiert, skopulos ist und alles mögliche.
Ich sehe aber nicht, dass er irgendwie freitritt oder so, sondern ich sehe,
dass er sehr, sehr selbstbewusst seine Interessen oder die der USA verteidigt.
Also meine Lesart ist ein bisschen anders als deine und sehr anders als die,
die wir gerade im Journalismus sehen.
Und beeindruckend ist ja, dass wir im Krieg zwei kleine Länder haben,
die die ganze Welt in Schach halten.
Also Russland, so groß wie Italien, aber spielt sich auch wie und so weiter.
Und wir haben jetzt auch immer wieder gehört.
Volkswirtschaftlich meinst du?
Genau, volkswirtschaftlich, aber halt Atomwaffen. Und wir haben ja jetzt auch
gehört, wie hart Putin da geblieben ist.
Weil ich stelle mir das so und so vor und das sind meine Vorstellungen und Trump
hat dann es damit allein.
Die Ukrainer noch kleiner. Also volkswirtschaftlich spielt es gar keine Rolle.
Militärisch auf verlorenem Posten sind so krass abhängig von ausländischer Unterstützung,
dass man wahrscheinlich in Tagen
einfach eine Kapitulation befürchten müsste, wenn da keine Hilfe ist.
So und jetzt haben aber beide Länder ganz schön viel rausgeholt für sich jeweils.
Also Putin hat es irgendwie geschafft, China auf seine Seite zu ziehen und Nordkoreaner
dazu zu bringen, ihre Bevölkerung dahin zu deportieren, damit die da irgendwie
als Kanonenfutter und so weiter.
Und bei der Ukraine ist ja auch sehr beeindruckend, wie weit sie gekommen sind.
Der Krieg dauert seit drei Jahren und man sieht null relevante Gebietsbewegung.
So, wie gelingt das? Also ich habe im Oval Office da einen sehr hilflosen Donald
Trump gesehen, der einfach nicht mehr weiter wusste.
Und ich habe einen Zelensky gesehen, der einfach in dieses Meeting reinging,
genau wusste, was es da geht.
Er wurde ja auch schon begrüßt mit seinem, wie siehst du denn aus,
was hast du denn da an und so weiter und so fort.
Und dann hat Zelensky so ein offenes Messer hingestellt und dann ist zuerst
Trump da reingeflogen und J.D. Vance ist noch hinterhergesprungen.
Zelensky wusste, um was es geht, nämlich diesen Deal. Und ich habe auch schon
gesagt, ich bin ein großer Anhänger dieser Stolperdraht-Theorie.
Also sobald Amerikaner auf ukrainischem Boden sind, sind die sozusagen unantastbar,
auch wenn es zivile Leute sind, die dort als Unternehmer irgendwelche Minen
ausbeuten und was auch immer.
Ja, eigentlich hätte ich auch gedacht, warum muss Trump jetzt nochmal Sicherheitsversprechen geben?
Es ist doch völlig klar, wenn dort Bodenschätze ausgeräumt werden von Amerikanern,
dann ist das ein automatisches Sicherheitsversprechen.
Da sind jetzt Amerikaner, da haben die Russen nichts zu suchen.
Und notfalls macht halt Trump dann die große Ansage und gibt einen Befehl.
So, er ist ja der Oberbefehlshaber.
So, also eigentlich hätte es diese Art von Sicherheitsversprechen.
Ja, und Trump sagt doch, er sei Präsident und man könne sich darauf verlassen,
dass da nichts passiert. Also er sagt jetzt ja nicht, welche Sicherheitsgarantien,
aber er hat mehrmals ja in dieser Pressekonferenz gesagt, sie reden da von anderen Präsidenten.
Wenn Putin sich da früher nicht dran gehalten hat, weiß ich nicht,
kann sein, da war ich nicht Präsident.
So und jetzt haben wir eine Lage, in der wir zwar alle über Trump jammern,
aber diese Argumentation von Trump hat eine inhärente Logik,
die bestechend ist, weil wir davon ausgehen können, dass Trump seinen Antlitz
nicht verlieren möchte, er ist am Ende dieser Strongman.
Also wenn da Minen in Gefahr sind, weil Amerikaner da keine Profite machen können,
dann steht natürlich das amerikanische Militär bereit, Standes ja immer.
Also deswegen, das ist ja die zentrale Funktion. So.
Nun hat sich aber Selensky nicht darauf eingelassen, sondern hat Chaos verursacht,
indem er gesagt hat oder gedacht hat, ich weiß, wie das hier läuft.
Also da sitzt jetzt der große Fürst der guten Gesellschaft und möchte alles in Interaktion klären.
Der trifft mich also locker am Auto, holt mich ab, dann gehen alle nochmal aufs
Klo, keiner spricht mit jemandem vorher.
Dann trifft man sich halt da und sagt, ja, coole Mien habt ihr da,
den Vertrag, den ihr da ausgearbeitet, der ist ja ganz cool,
können wir den jetzt unterzeichnen? Dann sagt der eine, nee.
Ja, dann sagt Zelensky einfach, nö, mach ich nicht. Reicht mir nicht. Ich will mehr. So.
Und dann lief ein Countdown. Und es war völlig klar, das Ding eskaliert.
Und Trump schickte ja auch keine Leute raus, bevor er nicht sein Deal bekommen
hat. Also standen die Journalisten alle ewig da.
So, und dann ging so eine Demütigungswelle los, als ob Zelensky nach drei Jahren
Krieg das beeindruckt, auf seine Klamotte angesprochen zu werden.
Ja, das war ja...
Völlig absurd.
Das war natürlich wieder dieser typische Irrsinn.
Und das Ding ist am Ende klar geendet. Es gab diesen Deal nicht und Trump stand ohne Deal da.
Er konnte natürlich dann den großen Zampano machen und so weiter,
aber wir haben doch gesehen, was das für politische Schockwellen in Europa hervorgerufen hat.
Ja, aber dann hat doch Trump immer gesagt, die Europäer sollen sich darum kümmern
und jetzt kümmern sich die Europäer dazu. Er hat doch genau das erreicht.
Er hat gesagt, seht ihr, ihr könnt euch nicht auf mich verlassen.
Mobilisiert eure Milliarden. Also das ist doch eine klare Strategie von Trump.
Lass mich einen Bogen schlagen. Also wir haben jetzt dieses Buch von Alex Karp.
Der hat ja politische Ideen.
Und jedes Mal, wenn er Amerika nennt, heißt es direkt im nächsten Halbsatz und
seine europäischen Alliierten.
So, die kann man also, wenn man so eine Idee hat, wie wir sie gleich diskutieren,
nicht aufs Spiel setzen.
So, jetzt haben wir aber Europäer, die sagen, Herbert Trump,
du hast doch immer gesagt, wir sollen uns um unsere eigene Sicherheit kümmern.
Und wenn jetzt der französische Präsident kommt und sagt, ja,
dann machen wir ein Konjunkturprogramm draus und unterstützen hier unsere Waffentechnologien
und dann sagen die Deutschen, ja, wir haben auch Waffentechnologien,
wir sind die drittbesten Verbreiterexporteure der Welt, wir können das auch
für uns selber bauen, wir brauchen nur das Budget.
Und es liegt ein Vorschlag auf dem Tisch, den selbst Friedrich Merz als großer
Gegner von Staatsverschuldung.
Er kriegt plötzlich 400 Milliarden dafür rausgeleiert.
So, das ist nicht im Sinne Amerikas. Und das ist eine Leistung, die Selenskyj,
in einer Interaktion hergestellt hat, in der er einfach nur gesagt hat,
ich weiß, wie eine Interaktion läuft.
Aber machen wir uns doch nichts vor.
Hier sind die Eigenrechte der Interaktion, also ist ja Lumens Diktum,
hier ist die Welt ausgeblendet.
Aber machen wir uns ja nichts vor. Das eine ist ja, dass die USA schon lange
wollen, dass Europa mehr aufrüstet und mehr beiträgt.
Ja, aber doch als Alliierte in Amerika kaufen.
Aber das werden sie jetzt auch tun.
Nein, das werden sie nicht tun.
Sie werden in Amerika kaufen.
Das werden sie nicht tun. Nein, werden sie nicht. Also das werden wir sehen,
das wird die Entwicklung sein.
Friedrich Merz muss ja noch hinreißen.
Die Gespräche in Europa laufen nicht darauf hinaus, dass man die Gelder,
die man jetzt mobilisiert, nach Amerika überweist, um sich amerikanische Wehrtechnik zu kaufen.
Nicht alles, aber zum Teil wird es wahrscheinlich so sein. Das kann sich Amerika
auf einen schlanken Fuß damit machen, indem Europa da selbst dann mehr macht.
Der Zug ist abgefahren, diese Niederlage muss Trump jetzt einstecken.
Ich würde es noch nicht als Niederlage begreifen. Also zum Beispiel Bojan Panschewski
schreibt, es geht Trump, er sagt dann aber auch, kann nach einem Telefonat sich
natürlich alles wieder ändern,
um die globale Einigung mit Russland, dauerhafte Deeskalation,
Rückkehr zum Handel, Entschärfung der Spannung mit Moskau, um sich auf China zu konzentrieren.
Russland und China so weit wie möglich voneinander trennen.
Im Grunde war vieles davon die Politik von Clinton, Bush, Obama, Biden.
Das hat aber nicht glänzend bisher funktioniert. Zweitens Beendigung des Krieges
in der Ukraine zu vernünftigen Bedingungen.
Die Ukraine ist ein Ärgernis für die US-Regierung und sie will,
dass das Problem gelöst wird.
Kiew kann damit arbeiten. Mehrere Beamte der beiden Administrationen haben zu
Protokoll gegeben, dass eine Entmalitarisierung und die Umwandlung der Ukraine
in einen russischen Vasallenstaat nicht einmal diskutiert, geschweige denn akzeptiert werden wird. Aha.
Trump wird es schwer haben, eins und zwei zu bekommen. Dafür gibt es strukturelle Gründe.
Also muss er einen anständigen Deal hinbekommen.
Welche Animositäten und Spannungen es auch immer geben mag, die USA,
werden die Ukraine auf keinen Fall im Stich lassen.
Auch interessant. Es gibt eine Politik und Bemühungen, den Krieg zu beenden.
Die Regierung Biden steckte ohne Plan in einer Schleife fest.
Denn auch das ist ja einfach wahr.
Biden hat nichts angeboten, außer Waffen, die den Krieg zwar noch weiter durchführbar
machen, aber den auch nicht gewinnen lassen.
Warum uns dahin köcheln, auszuholen?
Es gibt deshalb, sagt Julian Panschewski, Gründe für harten realpolitischen
Optimismus. Also so schätzt er das ein und das ist jetzt nun auch kein Trump-Freund.
Was doch klar ist, ist, dass die EU jetzt aufrüstet und Deutschland aufrüstet
und all das, um sich stärker einbringen zu können.
Aber was ja auch klar sein müsste und manchen Transatlantikern ist es inzwischen
auch klar, man wird sich ja nicht mit der EU in einen Zwei-Fronten-Krieg begeben.
Man wird ja nicht während Trump...
Beispielsweise jetzt mit Putin verhandelt und mit Zelensky wieder ins Gespräch
kommt, den Krieg weiter intensivieren durch Wassermann-Lieferungen.
Dass dann irgendein Journalist wie Felix Daxel oder wie sie alle heißen,
schreiben bei Twitter, Taurus jetzt, ist ja vollkommen irrsinnig.
Damit würde man ja quasi Krieg gegen Russland und auch noch gegen die Interessen der USA führen.
Das wird ja nicht der Fall sein. Also wird dieser Krieg in der Ukraine beendet
durch eine US-amerikanische Politik, bei der man hoffen kann.
Dass gewisse europäische Interessen da auch noch vertreten werden.
Das kommt dann darauf an, wie gut man verhandeln kann und wie klug sich zum
Beispiel Friedrich Merz anstellt.
Aber es ist ja keineswegs so, dass das jetzt hier für Trump eine verlorene Sache ist.
Und all das, was wir jetzt da gesehen haben, ist zwar an den Bildern und der
Stimmung und so einmalig, sowas hat
es so noch nicht gegeben bei einer Pressekonferenz von Regierungschefs.
Aber inhaltlich kann das ja niemanden überraschen, denn das ist ja genau das,
was Trump seit Monaten schon weit vor seiner Wahl angekündigt hat.
Dass dann jetzt Leute wie zum Beispiel der neue Grünen-Chef Jakob Lase bei Twitter schreiben.
Wer in dieser Weltlage noch immer zögert, Europas Freiheit auch mit Waffen zu
verteidigen, ist nicht links, sondern naiv und unsolidarisch.
Da frage ich mich dann schon, naja, die Weltlage ist nämlich erst seit vergangenen
Freitag so, wie sie ist und trotzdem ist ja da die einzig berechtigte Frage,
die die Alexander Jorde gestellt hat.
Du erinnerst dich, der Pfleger, der damals gegen Merkel und Spahn gewettert
hat. Und er fragte nämlich dann bei Twitter, wann startet deine Grundausbildung, Jakob Lasel?
Woraufhin er unglaublich viel Kritik bekam und böse beschimpft wurde,
wo ich einfach sagen würde, nein, das ist genau die richtige Frage, die zu stellen ist.
Denn wenn hier es ja heißt, wer noch zögert, also offenbar zögert ja Jakob Lasel
noch, der sei unsolidarisch, ja dann muss man sich ja diese Frage gefallen lassen.
Zu dem ja jemand wie Alexander Jorde seine Grundausbildung gemacht hat und im
Übrigen bei der Marine, die haben ja die schönsten Uniformen wie ich finde,
kann also so jemand auf jeden Fall eine solche Frage stellen.
Das ist aber jetzt gerade das politische Klima, in dem wir uns befinden und wo man nicht sehen will,
dass man nur jetzt mit Trump irgendwie es schaffen muss, dass es nicht ganz
so arg ausgeht für die Ukrainer und die Europäer, aber man wird jetzt nicht
mit europäischer Unterstützung Putin besiegen,
während Trump irgendwas anderes macht.
Wir müssen hier also in dem Fall wirklich ganz detailliert vorgehen.
Die Ukraine, also nicht die Ukraine, aber die Gebiete, die gerade von Russland
besetzt sind und die auch in der russischen Verfassung als russische Gebiete
schon aufgenommen sind.
Die werden entweder an Putin verloren gehen, dann beutet Putin das da aus, oder an die Amerikaner.
Dann gibt es diese etwas vageren, aber die werden jetzt wahrscheinlich auch
ein bisschen nachgerüstet, auch semantisch, Gebiete.
Also wird es dann Sicherheitsvorkehrungen geben, allein weil die Amerikaner sind.
Und sei es, dass man diese Minen, die von Amerikanern ausgebeutet werden und
was auch immer, dann durch Waffengewalt nochmal, und da reicht es ja völlig.
Das war ja auch immer in der sogenannten dritten Welt so, wenn die Amerikaner dort zugange waren.
Die Modelle sind ja sowieso schon seit ewig, also seit längerem jetzt, seit dem Irakkrieg,
dass da private Sicherheitsfirmen mit semistaatlichem Auftrag von privaten Firmen
angeheuert werden, die dann irgendwelche Steuersubventionen,
was auch immer, damit das nicht deren Kosten sind.
Also die Ukraine, was das angeht, ist verloren für Europa.
Entweder an Trump oder an Putin. Und ich sage jetzt Trump und Putin und nicht
Russland und Amerika, weil ich es so meine.
Davon unterschieden ist aber die Sicherheitsdiskussion Europas.
Wenn wir eine Befriedung haben, die darauf hinausläuft, dass Putin oder Trump
da irgendwelche Ausbeutungsgeschäfte zulässt,
dann stellt sich für die Europäer die Sicherheitsfrage neu, weil entweder ist
der große Treiber, Putin führt jetzt keinen Krieg mehr, also rüstet er gerade
aus, bereitet sich vor, also müssen wir uns auch vorbereiten.
Oder wir können nie wieder den Amerikanern vertrauen, weil nicht nur jetzt unter
Trump ist offensichtlich was
passiert, sondern die Stimmung war auch unter Obama und unter Biden so.
Sie bricht jetzt nur durch Trump aus, aber wir haben eine langfristige Entkopplung von Amerika.
So, und ich bin sehr davon überzeugt, dass wir zum einen einen neuen europäischen
Aufrüstungsdiskurs dahingehend kriegen,
dass Deutschland jetzt 400 Milliarden mobilisiert, Frankreich nochmal 200 Milliarden,
die Briten da wieder groß eingebunden werden,
dass Dahmer und seine Nachfolger dann auch wieder an EU-Gipfeln teilnehmen,
weil da auch demnächst über Wer und so weiter diskutiert wird.
So, das ist aber nochmal eine eigene Diskussion.
Also da rede ich über KI, Maschinen, Wehrtechnik und so weiter.
Die Wehrpflichtdiskussion.
Die machen wir jetzt gleich.
Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt in Deutschland. Die machen wir gleich.
Ja, weil ich bleibe dabei.
Lass mich nur da anknüpfen.
Also demografisch gesehen ist die Diskussion erledigt.
Stefan, ich wünsche mir nichts mehr, als dass du recht hast.
Marc Schiritz, den ich eigentlich als Transatlantiker im Kopf hatte,
schrieb im Zuge dessen, was im Weißen Haus geschah, etwas sehr interessantes auf Twitter.
Er sagte, ein globales Bündnis gegen die USA ist die letzte Chance des Westens.
China muss Teil dieses Bündnisses sein. Und das finde ich erstmal verrückt und
dann fand ich es aber interessant und dann fand ich es sogar vielleicht sehr klug, denn es ist ja so.
Wir haben jetzt diese NATO und all das und das wird jetzt auch erstmal noch so bleiben.
Also ich glaube, es ist auch jetzt nicht viel gewonnen, wenn man jetzt einfach
sagt, wir gehen da raus und so weiter.
Die Sache ist nur folgende, wenn es wirklich so ist, dass die USA,
und das gibt es ja durchaus auch von demokratischer Seite, diese Idee haben,
Adam Toos hat ja davor häufig gewarnt,
China sogar in eine schießende Auseinandersetzung, sprich in einen Krieg zu
verwickeln, weil man nicht haben will, dass da eine andere Weltmacht genauso stark ist oder stärker.
Dann, Gnade uns Gott, dann sind wir wirklich verloren.
Insofern zu überlegen, ob China, gerade weil da umweltpolitisch so viel passiert,
nicht doch ein Partner sein könnte, nicht mit dem wir alle Werte teilen,
aber mit wem teilen wir im Westen schon noch alle Werte, wenn wir an unsere
Postfaschisten und so weiter denken,
dann ist vielleicht diese Idee, die Shiriz hier artikuliert,
gar nicht blöde, auch wenn sie sehr utopisch erscheint, zumindest würde sie
einmal uns Europäer dazu bringen, aus dieser Blockkonfrontation,
die da von Amerika so sehr forciert wird.
Hinauszutreten und zu denken, wie können wir eigentlich wieder uns assoziieren mit anderen.
Denn es kann ja nicht hinauslaufen auf eine Welt, in der wir nur noch Blöcke
haben und wählen können, mit wem wir gerade Krieg führen wollen. Trump, Putin oder Xi.
Diese Kriege werden wir jedenfalls alle verlieren.
Als Soziologe ist mir nicht fremd, dass eine Beschreibung von Realität,
wie sie in der Zeitung steht eigentlich nur aktualisiert wie es längst ist.
Und das ist in dem Fall so.
Als es hieß, okay, es gibt jetzt irgendwie Zölle und die 800 Dollar Grenze für
Importe greift nicht mehr, das heißt die ganzen Mädels können ihre Schienensachen
nicht mehr bestellen US Postal Service liefert keine Pakete mehr aus, was bedeutet,
pro Jahr sind es 1,5 Milliarden Pakete die aus China auf diesem Wege nach Amerika
geliefert werden die liegen jetzt beim Zoll rum und müssen wieder zurückgeschickt werden.
So, 1,5 Milliarden, wir hören das so und denken, wow, das ist aber viel.
Aus China werden 4,5 Milliarden solcher Pakete nach Deutschland, nach Europa geliefert.
Wir haben Eisenbahnstrecken, wo kilometerlange Züge bis nach Duisburg durchfahren.
Wir haben einen Gesprächszusammenhang, der für die Tagesschau immer noch läuft,
wie sich Richard David Brecht darüber lustig macht, dass auch die Menschenrechte
angesprochen wurden und dann wurde irgendwer besucht.
Wobei dieser Besuch schon gar nicht mehr stattfindet. Jetzt werden nur noch
die Menschenrechte angesprochen.
Also dieser Blog aus China und Europa.
Der ist längst gegeben, wirtschaftlich auf jeden Fall.
Die Dinge, also dieser Wirtschaftsraum ist so eng beieinander,
so abhängig voneinander.
90 Prozent unserer Weihnachtsgeschenke, unserem Weihnachtsbaum und damit die
Lebensfreude in der dunklen Jahreszeit hängt davon ab, ob es in China ordentlich läuft.
So und wir sind eben auch in einer Schicksalsgemeinschaft.
Aber weiß Ursula von der Leyen das auch?
Ursula von der Leyen weiß das sehr.
Aber dann hätte sie nicht diese Zölle unbedingt gemacht. Ursula von der Leyen
hat ja diesen beiden Anti-China-Kurs mitgetragen. Soll ich dir sagen.
Wie diese Zölle gemacht werden?
Also Biden hat ja diesen Anti-China-Kurs von Trump übernommen.
Und Ursula von der Leyen sagte, wunderbar, da machen wir mit.
Und das war ja auch etwas, was Adam Tous kritisiert hat, was aber auch unterstützt
wurde von der Bundesregierung, zumindest vom grünen Teil der Bundesregierung
und zum Teil auch von der FDP.
Und da ist ja doch interessant, dass man jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr den Partner
in Crime in den USA sieht und man tatsächlich dazu übergehen könnte,
wie Schiritz das ausformuliert und wie du das jetzt gerade nochmal ganz plastisch
gemacht hast mit den Geschenken,
dass man doch sieht, dass man eigentlich mehr aneinander hat.
Und das ist, um das hier nicht irgendwie zu relativieren, natürlich ist jetzt
China nicht das präferierte Modell für uns, dass wir sagen, so müssen wir auch werden,
nur wir können gleich mal gucken, wie USA auch sein könnte unter Alexander Karp
und dann fragen wir uns, wo ist der Unterschied, beziehungsweise ist uns vielleicht
sogar doch doch China lieber.
Ich will mal, ich mache jetzt einen Brückenschlag, der ist, also ich mache eine Vermutung.
Aber auf der einen Seite weiß ich genau, wovon ich rede, auf der anderen Seite halt nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die EU-Kommission gerade mit der chinesischen kommunistischen
Partei kommuniziert. Niemand weiß das.
Aber ich weiß, wie die SPD und der DGB immer miteinander kommuniziert haben.
Wenn es hieß, die SPD muss ja mal einen Vorschlag machen zum Koalitionsfrieden,
dass die Arbeitnehmerrechte und so weiter.
Dann kündigt man sich an, sagt, wir brauchen mal einen Termin.
Dann sitzt der SPD-Vorsitzende und der DGB-Chef da und überlegen,
okay, dann machen wir das so.
Du sagst morgens im Deutschlandfunk das und dann reagiere ich 9 Uhr mit einer Pressemitteilung so,
und dann gehst du in die Fraktion und sagst das und dann 16 Uhr bereite ich
mich nochmal drauf vor, den Tagesthemen dann das zu sagen. Und dann wird das
einfach durchgespielt.
Und meine Vermutung ist, wenn die EU-Kommission und die Chinesen jetzt irgendwelche
Zollsachen austarieren müssen, weil es einen Zeitgeist gibt und man mit Trump
und so weiter, dann wird das genauso gemacht irgendwie.
Das ist, ich sehe jetzt nirgendwo, das ist ja auch, guck mal,
Trump kam ins Amt und hat gesagt, Nee, hier diese Zolldinger und so weiter,
jetzt gibt es alles nicht mehr.
Diese Pakete lagen auf den Schiffen und wurden in Amerika einfach nicht so.
In Deutschland, in Europa ist es ja so, die EU-Kommission kündigt an,
sich jetzt mal das Geschäftsgebaren von Schiinen anzuschauen.
Und dann geht so Zeit ins Land. Und dann kommt die nächste Pressekonferenz.
So, wir starten jetzt mal Ermittlungen.
Wir wissen nicht genau, wann die abgeschlossen sind.
Was ja zum Teil auch richtig ist.
Das zu machen.
Also es geht natürlich auch darum, dass da faire Bedingungen sind.
Und dass zum Teil das da mit Xi'in nicht alles so glatt läuft.
Das ist ja auch völlig klar, dass da nachgeguckt wird.
Nur, dass man diese Konfrontation nicht weiter beschleunigt.
Interessant ist ja auch, Wir haben jetzt gerade so ein Börsen-Down.
Dadurch, dass Trump Zölle verkündet.
Alle seine Gewinne seit Amtsantritt sind verloren gegangen.
Ja, also das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Und wenn man es dann mal vergleicht und
die Leute in der Finanzbranche, die vielleicht auch da auf Trump gesetzt haben,
tun das ja. Die haben das ja im Blick.
Man sieht sich den MICI World an oder den S&P 500.
Also S&P 500 beinhaltet die 500 wichtigsten amerikanischen Konzerne.
MSCI World hat einen ganz starken Schwerpunkt USA alles runtergesackt durch
diese Zollpolitik von Trump.
Man sieht sich mal eine China-ETF an und wird sehen, oh, der ist aber ganz schön im Plus.
Was ist denn da los? Und zwar seit Wochen, Monaten. Und das ist das Interessante.
1,5 Trillionen, also das, was nach der Billionen kommt, an Wert vernichtet.
Waren zwar nur Buchwerte und so, aber die spielen natürlich trotzdem eine Rolle. einfach weg.
Und das kann man nicht mit ein paar Steuererleichterungen wieder ausgleichen.
Das, was Trump da gerade macht, ist dumm. Und ich finde, man sieht jetzt in
allen oder in vielen Belangen, dass es ausgereizt ist.
Man kann immer nur so und so weit drohen. Also drohen kann man immer.
Man kann eine Drohne aktualisieren. Dann kann man nochmal drohen.
Die Drohung wieder deutlich machen und so weiter. Aber wenn man sie einmal.
Umsetzt, dann geht es an die Substanz. Und Trump muss die ganze Zeit umsetzen.
Der droht dem Kongress nichts an, sondern der muss die wirklich alle einbrauben
und verschießt das Pulver für eine in Anführungszeichen State of the Union.
Das kann er nicht jede Woche machen. Das war es jetzt erstmal.
Das war jetzt die große Ansprache.
Die nächsten drei Monate ist dann nichts möglich. Das Pulver ist verschossen.
25% Zölle gegen Kanada. Das Pulver ist verschossen. Hier ist nichts mehr zu drohen.
Die muss jetzt austariert werden. Die Leute haben die Hände voll,
damit jetzt diese Zettel da auszufüllen.
Wenn Trump jetzt nochmal sagt, 35% denken die alle nur auf, was für ein Scheiß.
Also überall ist das Pulver verschossen.
Und der große Vorteil von Trump, das können wir ja nochmal als Teaser für das
Buch sagen, der große Vorteil von Trump ist, dass er dumm ist.
Also als Sammelbecken für viele Strömungen gut funktioniert,
von denen jeder glaubt, ich setze mich durch.
Ich bin Elon Musk, ich brauche kluge, kreative Ausländer, ich setze mich durch.
Gleichzeitig haben aber die ganzen Neonazis hinter sich, die sagen,
gar keine Ausländer, auch nicht die superklugen, wir brauchen ein eigenes Bildungssystem.
Dann ist Jane Evans mit der Peter Thiel Idee und so weiter. Also es sind ganz
viele Ideen, die sich da kumulieren und eine von diesen Ideen kriegen wir ja
in diesem Buch ganz detailliert vorgestellt.
Und wir denken die ganze Zeit, wenn das die einzige Idee wäre,
die Trump gerade durchsetzt, Hut ab.
Aber er setzt vier solcher Ideen vor, die sich gegenseitig im Wege stehen.
Und dann müssen wir wirklich Angst haben. Also ein Doppelpräsident hat Vorteile.
So, aber dieses Projekt, was wir da detailliert sehen, geht nicht ohne internationale Allianz.
Ja, ja, aber es ist beängstigend, glaube ich, in noch mehrfacher Weise.
Der plant, man hat ja wieder in die Schublade für den nächsten Versuch.
Ja, beziehungsweise glaube ich, dass schon etwas hier ausgesprochen wird,
was als Stimmung wirklich im Raum ist und was man auch so in Deutschland finden kann.
Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht bei irgendwelchen rechten Tech-Analysten oder
so, sondern ich glaube, es ist etwas in der Luft und das ist beängstigend und
das wird hier in diesem Buch aufgegriffen.
Wir können eine wirklich gefährliche Teaser-Frage stellen.
Dieses Projekt, du hast ja immer das gedruckte Buch hier, ich gucke mal,
das sind ja beeindruckende, also auch beeindruckendes Literaturverzeichnis,
wirklich sehr ausführlich.
Ja, 200 Seiten.
Aber wir haben hier sehr viel Text, so 200 Seiten Text. Was ich mich beim Lesen
gefragt habe, warum verschwenden sie dieses gute, in sich schlüssige Projekt,
das sie da haben, also für sich gut, für mich nicht,
warum verschwenden sie es mit einer republikanischen Präsidentschaft?
Warum binden sie es nicht einem Demokraten ans Bein?
Also die Gefahr besteht auch, dass man in Amerika einen Diskurs auslöst,
indem es heißt, die Idee war so gut,
leider hat der erste Versuch nicht funktioniert durch Blödheit Trumps,
aber sollten wir es nicht mit den Demokraten machen.
Und wir wissen, die Shifts sind möglich.
Mark Zuckerberg, Elon Musk, das waren alles mal quasi Demokraten,
die die Vogue-Agenda und so
weiter durchgesetzt haben, die haben jetzt einen Shift gemacht zu Trump.
Die bleiben auch nach Trump und Palantir bleibt ja auch.
Ich glaube, es gibt genügend grüne Parteien, damit meine ich jetzt nicht nur
unsere Grünen, die dieses Programm dankbar aufgreifen würden.
Und das ist auch das Beängstigen daran.
Also es ist eben nicht jetzt, ach ja, so ein verrückter Tech-Analyst und ein
paar verrückte Reiche wollen irgendwas machen.
Ich glaube, es geht noch tiefer. Ich war im schönen Österreich, in Wien,
bin dort aufgetreten mit Jean-Philippe Kindler und Ole und hatte auch noch das
Vergnügen, durch das Labor eines Physik-Nobelpreisträgers geführt zu werden.
Ich habe also mit einem Quantenphysiker gesprochen und es war so,
dass das einen doch sehr demütig macht vor dem, was die Wissenschaft so leisten kann, von dem,
wie die Welt ist, beziehungsweise was sie im Innersten zusammenhält und dass
man es doch am Ende vielleicht gar nicht so genau sagen kann,
dass wir doch irgendwo wieder einen Schritt in die Metaphysik gehen.
Ja, es ist also völlig logisch, dass man diesen Schritt nimmt.
Nun bin ich ja schon religiös, deswegen muss ich es nicht erst noch werden.
Aber es war wirklich hochinteressant zu sehen und für mich ein ganz besonderes Erlebnis.
Aber natürlich ist Österreich auch noch was anderes. Da gab es den Opernball ein paar Tage vorher.
In der Fernsehübertragung sehen wir hier Miriam Weichsebraun,
die jetzt in so einer Loge in der Staatsoper den Außenminister Alexander Schallmberg interviewt.
Und du bist ja ein Verfechter, könnte man sagen, der nuklearen Aufrüstung in
Europa oder in Deutschland.
Die Österreicher haben es natürlich wieder ganz anders für sich gelöst.
Das ist Österreich. Und dafür habe ich jetzt sechs Jahre im Ausland gearbeitet.
Das ist unser Soft Power.
Es gibt die Hard Power. Und wir haben vielleicht keine Atomwaffen,
wir haben Wolfgang Matthäus Mozart.
Die Österreicher machen es einfach mit Mozart. Ist das nicht toll?
Ja, finde ich gut.
Falls man sich fragt, ich habe nicht so lange POVI studiert,
was ist noch meine Soft Power? Mozart.
Mozart. Ganz, ganz einfach. Und es wirkt. Und tatsächlich, überall wird ja Mozart gespielt.
Noch mal ganz kurz zu dieser Wehrpflicht. Es gab einen Kulturzeitbeitrag,
in dem kam auch Ole vor, das spielen wir jetzt nicht.
Aber es gab dort auch eine Frau Professorin Grohe von der Bundeswehruniversität,
die mit folgendem Statement in dem Beitrag vorkommt.
Denn im Ernstfall ist die Wehrpflicht kein Gebot, sondern eine Pflicht.
Der Staat muss wehrfähig sein, um sich zu wehren.
Diese Wehrfähigkeit stellt der Herr, indem er seine Bürger heranzieht.
So was funktioniert nicht auf rein freiwilliger Basis, das heißt, da muss ein Zwang her.
Wir Bürger, Bürgerinnen verteidigen unsere freiheitlich-demokratische Gesellschaft
gegen Angriffe und Zerstörung von außen.
Und das ist eine gesamtgesellschaftliche Pflicht. Und die darf dann auch von
60-Jährigen verlangt werden, von 18-Jährigen.
Und da sagst du einfach, ja, so ist es halt.
Zum Glück bin ich alt. Also Amerika, die ja die Welt dominieren,
der Hegemon sind, 900 Milliarden Verteidigungsbudget durchballern,
die lösen das auch in der Wehrpflicht.
Habe ich irgendwie nicht so ganz mitbekommen, wo die Logik ist.
Ich finde es so interessant, dass sie sagt, es braucht den Zwang und redet dann
im nächsten Satz von der Freiheit.
Also das ist ja auch das Interessante, dass die ganze Zeit die Leute,
die so viel von Freiheit reden,
laufen und die schon eine Einschränkung daran sehen, wenn eine Steuer erhoben
wird oder so und sagen, jetzt wird aber meine Freiheit beschnitten,
die dann zugleich sagen, naja, also bei Militär, also da muss schon ein gewisser
Zwang her, da muss schon Ordnung und Disziplin sein.
Es ist verrückt. Ich finde auch interessant, dass es nicht eine große Rebellion
gibt bislang, obwohl diese Pläne ja auf dem Tisch liegen für eine Wiedereinführung
der Wehrpflicht seitens der Eltern.
Also ich kriege es nicht so ganz zusammen. Wir haben doch dieses Phänomen Helikoptereltern.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen größer, als man denkt, aber es ist ja in der
Tat so, dass mir zum Beispiel Lehrer erzählen, sie geben im Aufsatz eine Vier,
sofort stehen die Eltern auf der Matte, sagen, wir können auch mal den Rechtsanwalt mitbringen.
Früher hat man auch mal Kinder, wenn sie sich nicht benommen haben,
im Unterricht vor die Tür gesetzt, dann kommt gleich psychische Schäden, traumatisiert etc.
Also wir haben diese hypersensibilisierten Eltern, die aber offenbar überhaupt
nicht hypersensibilisiert sind, wenn es um die Wehrpflicht geht.
Nein, ich verstehe nicht.
Warum.
Was ist so schwer daran zu beobachten? Die Eltern gehen auf die Matte,
wenn das eigene Kind eine Vier hat.
Die machen aber keine Demonstrationen vorm Rathaus gegen Vieren allgemein.
Wenn der Brief im Briefkasten landet, dann ist die Diskussion klar.
Glaubst du?
Diese Eltern haben die Hände voll. Ich erlebe es doch an mir selber.
Aber du glaubst wirklich, dass dann, wenn die Wehrpflicht da ist, dass es dann Ärger gibt?
Also wenn ich eine Überzeugung habe, dass es nicht möglich ist,
in Deutschland jemandem einen Brief nach Hause zu schicken, in dem drin steht,
dein 18-jähriger Sohn, den du so und so viel zum Musikunterricht, zur Schule,
zum Sport gefahren hast, Den brauchen wir morgen in der Kaserne.
Vor allem nicht, wenn du den dann da hinbringst und dann da siehst,
das ist die Kaserne, dann ist Krieg in Deutschland.
Stefan, mögest du Recht haben?
Bevor wir Deutschland mit einer Wehrpflicht im Äußeren verteidigen, ist hier Bürgerkrieg.
Das ist wirklich eine ganz feste Überzeugung und ich habe mich sehr viel mit
Familie und Gemütszuständen und demografischen Grundlagen und Mangellagen befasst.
Im Zuge unserer Folge hat mir eine Hörerin auch einen Hinweis gegeben im Presseclub.
Vom vergangenen Sonntag war unter anderem der Journalist Marc Prost zu Gast.
Der äußert sich zur Aufrüstung und diesen Sondervermögen wie folgt.
Was ganz schwierig ist, und das haben wir eben gesehen seit dem 24.
Februar 2022, ist den Menschen zu erklären, warum wir das tun,
warum wir die Ukraine verteidigen, wer uns eigentlich angreift.
Und da sind wir wieder bei einem Punkt der putinschen Kriegsführung,
warum er, da bin ich ja ganz bei Ina Ruck im Augenblick im Kreml,
sich das anschauen kann wie eine Kinoshow.
Die Destabilisierung westlicher Demokratien, die innere Zersetzung des Diskurses
ist auch ein Teil der russischen hybriden Kriegsführung.
Das heißt, diese Veränderung, die wir jetzt erleben, trifft auf ein aufgerautes
Land, das nicht nur wegen drei Jahre Ampel gerade mental ein bisschen am Boden
ist, sondern man muss wahnsinnig viel erklären, machen und tun.
Wir müssen unter Umständen über eine Wehrpflicht reden. Wir müssen darüber reden,
ob unsere Kinder wieder tatsächlich dieses Land verteidigen müssen.
Das sind alles ganz schwierige Debatten.
Mein Sohn ist 17 Jahre, ich möchte auch nicht, dass er in den Krieg ziehen muss.
Aber das sind alles Dinge, die wirklich jetzt Führung erfordern und eine große
mentale Veränderung. Der Rest ist ehrlich gesagt politische Routine.
Da ist wieder das Wort Führung und da wird also jetzt schon der Journalismus
darauf eingeschworen, eine Stimmung herzustellen, bei der dann irgendwann alle
einwilligen und sagen, ja, es muss aber auch leider sein, mein 17-Jähriger muss auch los.
Journalisten haben in diesem Land nichts mehr zu sagen. Niemand guckt den Presseclub,
außer 75-jährige Omis. Wirklich, hier muss man jetzt...
Aber bei Twitter sind es doch auch die Jungen, hier Jakob Blase und diese jungen
Grünen, die sind doch genauso verrückt.
Du glaubst doch, wenn du den jungen Grünen jetzt eine vorlegen solltest,
Wehrpflicht einführen, dann würden die doch höchstens noch fragen,
ja aber ist das auch gleichberechtigt, damit auch Nonbinäre beim Militär dienen würden?
Das wäre doch die einzige Frage, die die noch stellen, um dann einzuwilligen.
Also die letzten jungen Grünen haben als kollektive Entscheidung gesagt,
nicht nur diese Partei nicht, sondern dieses System nicht.
Dass danach eine junge grüne Generation nachrücken gelassen wird,
die natürlich wieder auf den, komm wir machen euch wieder Versprechen,
ihr seid die Neuen, ihr könnt hier aufsteigen, dass die nachplappern,
was sie irgendwo lesen, ja.
Aber sorry, völlig ausgeschlossen. Ich sage es heute und ich habe schon ein
paar harte Sachen gesagt und die waren auch richtig am Ende.
Niemand konnte sich vorstellen, dass März 500 Milliarden Sondervermögen so, außer wir.
Wir haben es schon vor Jahren gesagt und jetzt ist der Moment da und ich sage,
Wehrpflicht kann man diskutieren, so viel man will.
Den ersten Brief in den Briefkasten reinstecken, lesen lassen und dann mal gucken, was passiert.
Du bist ja auch bei Threads, da bin ich nicht.
Nee, da bin ich nicht. Ich schicke da nur automatisiert meine stefanschulz.com.
Blogartikel. Achso, aber du hast mir irgendwas von Threads geschickt.
Das konntest du vielleicht mal vortragen.
Ah, oh, ja, das ist natürlich.
Das hat mich wahnsinnig gefreut.
Dass du mich da mit konfrontiert hast. Ich gehe in meine Meta-Messages um.
Also über Instagram hast du mir einen Screenshot geschickt.
Ja, den trage ich gerne vor. Ich weiß grob, worum es geht. Also.
Also, Paul Ronsheimer schreibt, das Interesse an der außenpolitischen Lage nach
dem Zelensky-Trump-Eklat und der Anknüpfung des Waffen-Stops ist riesig. Auch bei Podcasts.
Piatow und ich haben gestern Nacht aktuell produziert, aus Kiew natürlich,
dazu in den vergangenen Tagen Folgen mit und so weiter. wir wissen ja,
Ronsheimer macht ja immer am 13.
Tag des Monats den 11. Podcast und das ist jetzt keine ausgedachte Zahl.
Daraufhin nimmt warte mal, Micky Beisenherz ne, das ist ja, ich bin hier im falschen,
Ach hier. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Wir gehen ans Eingemachte.
Ich lese vor. Friedemann Karich schreibt, Es war eine Falle,
um den Verrat der USA an Ukraine und NATO und die Allianz mit Putin zu legitimieren.
Es ist aber auch die größte Chance für Europa, sich jetzt zu einem echten Gegengewicht zu vereinen.
Und so wird Friedrich Merz noch vor Amtsantritt der vielleicht wichtigste Politiker der freien Welt.
Ich habe dir das aus Gründen geschickt.
Ja, weil ich mich natürlich wahnsinnig darüber freue. Es war Karneval.
Es war Karneval, ja. Und das ist Karneval.
Das ist Karneval.
Das ist, wenn die Ordnung auf den Kopf gestellt wird. Siehst du,
da vielleicht Friedrich Merz, dass du sagst, für den würde ich aber schon kämpfen
wollen, für die freie Welt.
Ja. Friedrich Merz ist ja nicht, sich nicht zu blöde, die 500 Milliarden jetzt
schon wieder mit irgendwelchen Bürgergeldverrechnungen zu machen. Söder sekundiert das.
Das ist unsere freie Welt. Für die werden wir gemeinsam mit Friedemann Karech kämpfen.
Was haben wir bei der Impfpflicht immer gesagt? Bei der Impfpflicht haben wir
irgendwann festgestellt, nachdem es da plötzlich so zur Diskussion gab,
ah, da gibt es so Leute, die nutzen jetzt die Gelegenheit, um dem Staat zu sagen,
du hast nie etwas für mich getan, also tue ich nichts für dich.
Es ist egal, was du von mir willst, in dem Fall ist es eine Impfung, kriegst du nicht.
Das ist der Modus. Die Leute gucken nicht Presseclub und lassen sich dann irgendwie,
und der Merz ist jetzt der Führer der freien Welt und übrigens auch dein Bundeskanzler.
Ja, ich habe dann gedacht, wie kann man sagen, das ist jetzt irgendwie hier
der Mann der freien Welt und sowas.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, irgendwie geht das doch gar nicht so alles überein, oder?
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, als du mir das schicktest, ich höre mal kurz rein.
Es gibt dann den, mit Samira El-Wassil und Friedemann Karich,
diesen Piraten-Sender-Powerplay-Podcast.
Und dann reden die da tatsächlich über Friedrich Merz und ich habe jetzt einfach
mal so einen längeren Clip, der geht eigentlich noch viel, viel länger,
in dem Friedemann Karich, bevor er das geschrieben hat, über Friedrich Merz redet.
Und dann können wir uns ja nochmal fragen, ob es zwei Friedemann Karichs gibt
oder zwei Friedrich Merz.
Das ist eigentlich die Frage, die man sich da stellt.
Eins muss man Friedrich Merz wirklich lassen. Er ist der konsequenteste Kanzler,
den man sich für Deutschland gerade vorstellen kann.
Weil er, finde ich, alles das, was ich an Deutschland nicht mag,
in sich vereint. Also er ist ein aufbrausender Seriositätsdarsteller.
Der einerseits mit großer Geste im November einen fairen Wahlkampf und eine
Abgrenzung nach rechts verspricht und beides superlässig bricht,
sobald es ihm irgendwie zu nützen scheint.
Der ist nie bereit, sich zu korrigieren oder mal einen Fehler zuzugeben,
aber immer bereit für unfaire Attacken gegen seine Gegner, gegen Arme,
gegen Andersaussehende und Andersdenkende, wie jetzt eben mit dieser Anfrage.
Der ist diese Attitüde, solange ihr eure Füße unter meine Bundesrepublik stellt,
das ist er auf zwei Beinen und einer Haarinsel.
Das ist jemand, der sich durch hochdotierte Mandate, Wirtschaftskompetenz selber
zuspricht, was auch so deutsch ist und nicht checkt, dass das eigentlich nur
ein großer Ausdruck seiner Privilegien ist.
Er ist ein Dampfplauderer und Wichtigtuer, der immer irgendwo was zu melden
haben muss, der pathetisch mit seinem Gewissen argumentiert,
um seinen eigentlich grenzenlosen Opportunismus zu überspielen.
Und dann drei Wochen später, als alle anderen längst eingesehen haben,
dass er mit seinen angeblich vom Gewissen getriebenen Forderungen in der Migrationspolitik
komplett daneben lag, die Position dann räumt.
Aber ohne das wirklich zuzugeben, das könnte natürlich jemand wie Friedrich
Merz, wie der typische Deutsche nicht. Er hört sich gerne reden,
wäre gerne Volksner, hat aber eigentlich, glaube ich, so große Angst vor Menschen,
dass er lieber den Privatflieger nimmt als mal die Bahn.
Er ist rechtsoffen und hat Angst vor Links, weil er das nicht versteht und schon
gar nicht, was an Rechts so schlimm ist, weil es ihn ja persönlich nicht drohen würde.
Ich glaube, Friedrich Merz hält es oft für ein politisches Talent,
die Leute im Zweifel schamlos anzulügen.
Und gesteht sich das auch alles selbstgerecht, glaube ich, zu,
aus der Kränkung heraus gegen eine Frau verloren zu haben, was auch so unfassbar deutsch ist.
Ja, und dann können wir uns ja nochmal überfragen, ob das jetzt der tolle Anführer
der freien Welt ist. Kann jeder für sich selbst beantworten.
Und wir leiten über zu dem Buch.
Ich halte übrigens Friedrich Merz auch für einen Loser einfach.
Also wirklich mit 28,5 Prozent.
Ja, das ist ja überhaupt kein tolles Ergebnis.
Das ist einfach katastrophal. Das ist so schlecht.
Und er hatte ja noch...
Wenn man überhaupt eine Bundestagsmehrheit zusammenkriegt, um den Kanzlerposten
zu haben. Aber danach müssen eigentlich die Tore offen stehen.
Für, ich mache ja mal Koalitionsfrieden und na klar mache ich Zugeständnisse und überhaupt und so.
Er war ja bei dieser Bildgala, wir haben ja ausführlich drüber gesprochen und
hatte dort doch erst seine Spendenhöhe daran knüpfen wollen,
wie erfolgreich die CDU abschneidet und da sprach er ja von 40%.
Es ist einfach absurd.
Sehr weit entfernt.
Wir müssen uns jetzt trauen, die Loser auch als Loser zu beobachten.
Wir können nicht immer die ganze Zeit, oh ich habe so Angst vor Trump,
weil der hat ja Atomwaffen und so.
Trump ist ein Loser, Merz ist ein Loser, es sind alles Loser.
Kämpfen für Friedrich Merz ist wirklich keine gute Idee. Wir sprechen jetzt
über dieses wirklich spektakuläre Buch.
The Technological Republic, Hard Power, Soft Belief and the Future of the West von Alexander C.
Karp und Nikolas W. Semiski.
Semiska, Sie beide sind von Palantir und legen uns Ihre Visionen ganz offen dar.
Eigentlich eine Dystopie, für Sie ist das eine Utopie.
Wir müssen darüber ausführlich reden. Ich habe mich aufgrund dieser Lektüre dann entschlossen,
doch noch mit dem Manifest des Una-Bombas zu warten für den nächsten Monat,
weil ich nicht noch was Gruseliges lesen wollte, sondern habe dann als Gegengift, wenn man so möchte.
Y2K gelesen.
Hast du vielleicht schon von gehört, von Colette Shade, eine Journalistin.
How the 2000s became everything.
Sie erzählt also die Geschichte, die popkulturelle, digitale und ein bisschen
auch die politische Geschichte der 2000er Jahre und zeigt, wie sich alles so
veränderte und was uns davon heute noch prägt.
Ein kurzweiliges Buch, ein Buch, das eben nicht so dystopisch auf die Welt blickt
und gerade nicht auf diese Consumer-Kultur, die Alexander Karp so sehr abstraft.
Außerdem ist zur richtigen Zeit ein kurzer Roman erschienen von Lukas Meisel,
der beschäftigt sich mit dem Mann,
der damals nichts tat, oder das Richtige tat, indem er nichts tat,
der nämlich als ein Alarm angezeigt wurde, nicht darauf reagierte und sagte,
das kann nur ein Fehlalarm sein.
Wir können hier nicht von der Sowjetunion aus jetzt davon ausgehen,
dass die Amerikaner die...
Das Atomprogramm gezündet haben. Und damit hat er tatsächlich das Ende der Welt verhindert.
Und da gibt es einen kurzen Roman zu, den sollte man jetzt unbedingt lesen.
Außerdem gibt es noch von mir Musik, diesmal Benjamin Britten,
aus der FAZ einen kurzen Bericht über die.
Rekrutierer in der Ukraine und das brutale Vorgehen und ein Artikel über einen
Ring, mit dem sich Paare gegenseitig überwachen können.
Ja, sehr gut. Ich habe auch eine Antidote oder wie das heißt,
einen Gegenentwurf zu Alex Karp, denn die Direktorin des Bundesinstituts für
Bevölkerungsforschung, klingt natürlich gleich super sexy,
Katharina Spieß hat im Wirtschaftsdienst einer, das ist natürlich Special Interest,
ich habe einen höheren Hinweis dazu bekommen,
zum Thema Förderung der frühen Bildung und in alternden Gesellschaften,
worüber man so nachdenken muss, brauchen wir ein Bundesprogramm für Kitas.
Ich möchte gerne vorher schon sagen, das ist viel näher dran an der Wehrpflichtdiskussion,
wenn man sie ernsthaft über Verteidigungsfähigkeit, Willigkeit und gibt es eigentlich
was zu verteidigen, führen möchte, ja? Dann sollte man in diese Richtung denken.
Dann stelle ich zwei Texte gegenüber. Zum einen hat Kevin Ruse in der New York
Times darüber geschrieben,
wie es ist, jetzt ohne Coding-Kenntnisse Code zu produzieren,
Software herzustellen durch KI-Hilfe und in seinem Markus on AI Newsletter hat
der ehemalige Professor für Psychologie und eben heute KI-Unternehmer selbst, Markus,
glaube ich seinen Nachnamen nicht, naja jedenfalls Markus,
Gary Markus heißt er, so heißt er,
eine Antwort darauf geschrieben, wo die Gefahren liegen.
Kleine individuelle Vorteile, klar, die sind da, aber haben wir es ja vielleicht
auch mit großen Problemen zu tun.
Dann hat Philipp Hopf in seinem Hopf und Hate Podcast über sein Lieblingsbuch gesprochen.
Ich habe Claude danach gefragt, was hat es mit dem Buch auf sich?
Wir gehen Claudes Antworten durch und schauen in einen Text von Anne Applebaum.
Sie hat im The Atlantic über den neuen Amerikaner gesprochen.
Den brutalen Amerikaner, wie er uns gezeigt wurde. Denn der ist ja gar nicht so neu.
Er hat jetzt nur die Vorderbühne betreten. Und da gibt es so ein paar Sachen,
über die wir mal nachdenken müssen.
Und außerdem finde ich das aus akademischen Kniffen einen sehr guten Text.
Wir haben sie ja sehr kritisiert für ihren...
Klar, sie hat die Gelegenheit genutzt. Wir müssten eigentlich auch das Auswahlkomitee
kritisieren, dafür überhaupt einen Applebaum Friedenspreis des deutschen Buchhandels zu geben.
Aber es sind nun mal kriegerische Zeiten und ein paar Gedankengänge sind ja
gar nicht so schlecht. Also gehen wir einem nach, den ich gut finde.
Dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Ich will noch darauf hinweisen,
dass ich in diesem Monat in Duisburg und in Reutlingen zu Gast bin.
Das findet man alles auf meiner Homepage wolfgangmschmidt.de.
Sehr gut. Ich habe auch zwei Termine im April fürs Buch, einen in Karlsruhe, einen in Wien.
Ich habe es noch nicht auf der Webseite eingetragen, aber werde ich jetzt die Tage machen.
Und in den Salon kommt man ganz einfach, man geht auf neue20er.de,
das ist auch die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen und geht
dann auf den goldenen Button, dann kommt man zu Steady und ab drei Euro im Monat
kann man dann den Salon abonnieren und kann natürlich auch alle alten Folgen hören.
Also es sind dutzende Bücher, hunderte Bücher sind es inzwischen,
über die wir gemeinsam oder auch einzeln gesprochen haben, die wir empfohlen haben.
Viele Texte auch zum Silicon Valley, um das es ja heute wieder gehen wird.
Es ist natürlich auch möglich, diesen Salon über Patreon zu abonnieren oder
auch über Apple ist das ganz einfach mit einem Klick möglich.
Genau, wir haben eine Präferenz für Steady, weil wir bei Steady zum Beispiel
dieses vor dem Salon, im Salon, alles in einem Rutsch als eine Datei zur Verfügung stellen.
Das ist für sehr viele sehr einfacher und bei Steady gibt es den Salon und den
Podcast, also ab sofort alles komplett vollständig bei Steady.
Für Patreon wird es weiter geteilt sein also da bucht man normal Patreon,
kriegt er den Salon und muss den Rest über den öffentlichen Feed hören bei Apple
ist ja sowieso alles miteinander verschränkt, das ist ja da sehr praktisch Wunderbar.
Dann sehen wir uns im Salon Bis gleich.